Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір.
З новинами спорту - Норберт Леман.
Розпочнімо з саміту «Великої сімки»,
що проходить у Баварії, в замку Ельмау.
Президент США Байден та канцлер Німеччини Шольц
закликали до єдності у протидії Росії.
Знову обстріли Києва:
росіяни вдарили ракетами по столиці.
З-під завалів зруйнованого будинку
вдалося врятувати семирічну дівчинку.
Радість через золото на чемпіонаті
світу з водних видів спорту:
завдяки Флоріану Веллброку збірна
Німеччини здобула звання чемпіона світу
в естафеті з плавання на відкритій воді.
Саміт на тлі війни: «Нас об'єднує віра у демократію
та верховенство права», -
зазначив канцлер Німеччини на початку зустрічі.
Президент США також наголосив,
що нам варто триматися разом.
Перший пункт програми - традиційне групове фото.
Посередині - очільники Італії, Канади, Франції,
Німеччини, США, Великої Британії та Японії.
Ліворуч та праворуч від них - лідери ЄС:
Шарль Мішель та Урсула фон дер Ляєн.
Про перші години саміту розповість Даніель Понтцен.
На цих кадрах канцлер Німеччини
Олаф Шольц просить Джо Байдена,
президента США, обернутися,
щоб зробити спільне фото.
На таких самітах фото дуже важливі,
особливо зараз, коли так важливо
продемонструвати згуртованість.
Великого значення набувають і дружні жести.
Так Джо Байден ще до розмови віч-на-віч
не скупився на добре слово.
Вітаю з успіхами, яких ви досягли,
відколи стали канцлером.
Ваша політика дуже вплинула на всю Європу,
особливо з огляду на ситуацію в Україні.
Війна Росії проти України - найбільша проблема серед
численних багатопланових криз сучасності.
Я дуже радий, що ми маємо
так багато часу для спілкування.
Цей саміт значно відрізняється від
типових формалізованих зустрічей.
Кожен учасник має можливість говорити про те,
що для нього важливо.
Вже перше засідання було дуже ефективним.
Теми обговорення: виклики світової економіки,
дефіцит енергії, ланцюги поставок та інфляція.
У центрі уваги також
загострення продовольчої кризи.
За словами президента Європейської ради,
у цьому винна лише Росія.
Вона розігрує небезпечну карту голоду.
Через блокування бортів, атаки на об'єкти
критичної інфраструктури та перетворення
пшеничних полів на поля битви
цілі сім'ї та, зокрема, діти потерпають від голоду.
Ввечері на третьому робочому засіданні
лідери «Великої сімки» обговорюватимуть
зовнішню політику та політику безпеки.
Ці та інші теми стосуються зокрема й
запрошених країн, великих демократій:
Індії, Індонезії та Південної Африки.
Завтра вони також візьмуть участь в обговореннях.
Ми хочемо показати світу, що, працюючи разом,
демократії прокладають найкращий шлях
до досягнення значних результатів для
населення ЄС та людей у всьому світі.
Неважливо, чи йдеться про захист клімату,
охорону здоров'я, безпеку чи цифрові інновації.
Погода, атмосфера, пейзаж - усе відповідає настрою.
Досі незрозуміло, чи справді в результаті
саміту вдасться досягти значних звершень.
Саміт триватиме три дні.
Наразі поблизу замку Ельмау
перебуває наша кореспондентка Анна Ґеллінек.
Яка головна мета зустрічі лідерів «Великої сімки»?
Основний посил, який має надійти
звідси в Москву, -
згуртованість та готовність безстроково й надалі
підтримувати Україну.
Що довше триває ця війна,
то важче Заходу зберігати єдність.
Це ні для кого не секрет.
Сім очільників держав та урядів сьогодні
обговорювали найсерйозніші
економічні наслідки війни,
зокрема підвищення цін на енергоносії.
Саме тут й виникають помітні розбіжності у поглядах.
Президент США Джо Байден бажає
зниження цін на російську нафту.
Європейці налаштовані скептично щодо
зниження цін на енергоносії у всьому світі.
Відкритим також залишається питання
щодо того, яку важку зброю Захід надалі
постачатиме Україні, не ставши
учасником війни.
Усі ці питання очільники країн «Великої сімки»
й обговорюватимуть разом із
найближчими радниками за вечерею.
Наживо з саміту в замку Ельмау. Дякую.
Сьогодні знову відбулися протести
проти саміту країн «Великої сімки».
За даними поліції, у найбільшій
демонстрації, що відбулася
у Ґарміш-Партенкірхені, взяло участь 800 осіб.
Переважно мирну ходу демонстрантів
супроводжувало чимало
співробітників служби безпеки.
Загалом протестів значно менше, ніж очікувалося.
Усі оновлення щодо саміту «Великої сімки»
ви знайдете у нашому застосунку «ZDFheute».
Більше інформації про останні події
читайте у рубриці «Live-Blog».
Завтра Президент України Зеленський
виступить на саміті в онлайн-форматі.
Він вимагає терміново надати країні більше зброї.
Адже наразі Україна перебуває у
морально та емоційно складній фазі війни.
На сході росіяни захоплюють
дедалі більше нових територій.
Сьогодні, вперше за довгий час,
вони знову обстріляли Київ.
Детальніше розповість Пабло Зилалахі.
Семирічна дівчинка спала,
коли у її дім влучила російська ракета.
Вранці дитину та її маму змогли врятувати
з-під завалів житлового будинку.
Повідомляється, що вночі по Києву та його околицях
росіяни випустили щонайменше 14 ракет.
Одна з них влучила у територію дитячого садка.
Це перша ракетна атака на Київ
за останні три тижні.
На думку мера міста Кличка,
росіяни обстріляли столицю
з огляду на саміти «Великої сімки» і НАТО,
який розпочнеться вже цього вівторка.
Це не випадковість. Мабуть, атака саме у ці
дні, напередодні зустрічей,- символічна.
Президент Зеленський вважає, що
зараз, на четвертий місяць, триває важка фаза війни.
Ми не відчуваємо часових рамок.
Не знаємо, скільки ще ударів,
трат, зусиль буде, перш ніж ми побачимо,
що перемога вже на горизонті.
Зеленський зазначив, що Україна відвоює
усі міста, які наразі контролює Росія.
Вчора російські війська захопили стратегічно важливе
місто Сєвєродонецьк на Сході України,
тож тепер мають намір просуватися
через річку до сусіднього міста Лисичанськ.
Сьогодні Росія опублікувала ось ці кадри.
Міністр оборони Шойгу зустрівся з солдатами,
які воюють в Україні.
Незрозуміло, де саме було зроблено це відео.
Впродовж останніх тижнів Росія
зосереджувала свої війська
на Сході України для посиленого наступу.
Однак зараз Москва знову
націлилася на міста на заході країни.
На партійному з'їзді у місті Ерфурт Партія Лівих також
висловила свою позицію щодо війни в Україні.
Партія гостро розкритикувала дії Росії,
хоча й надалі виступає
проти постачання зброї Україні.
Вчора делегати обрали нових співголів партії.
Перемогу здобули Жанін Вісслер і Мартін Ширдеван.
Попереду складний раунд переговорів
щодо встановлення тарифів.
Профспілки вимагають компенсації інфляції,
проте це може лише посилити зростання цін.
Згідно із даними преси, канцлер Німеччини Шольц
пропонує можливий вихід: роботодавці здійснять
одноразові виплати, які не будуть оподатковуватися.
Своєю чергою профспілки мають пом'якшити
вимоги щодо заробітної плати.
На початку липня Шольц має намір поговорити
з роботодавцями та профспілками
про інфляцію та її наслідки.
Ще одна ідея від Федерального уряду:
через дефіцит фахівців в аеропортах Німеччини
уряд планує наймати іноземних спеціалістів.
Головна мета - вже з липня залучити
до роботи тисячі працівників.
У багатьох аеропортах сезон відпусток
розпочався із суцільного хаосу.
За даними дослідження, наразі
бракує майже 7200 співробітників.
Наприклад, у відділі прийому багажу.
Вітаємо німецьких плавців, що брали участь
в естафеті з плавання на відкритій воді.
Вони знову стали чемпіонами світу.
Так, вони доклали чимало зусиль, і успішно
захистили своє звання.
Квартет, до якого увійшли Олівер Клемет,
Леа Бой, Леоні Бек та Флоріан Веллброк,
здобув золото в естафеті 4 х 1,5 км.
Під час змагання панував невеликий хаос.
Леа Бой, плавчиня, що починає естафету,
єдина зі збірної здобула своє звання
на останньому чемпіонаті світу.
Це корисний досвід, тому що її
конкуренти-чоловіки скоротили шлях
і були за це
дискваліфіковані.
Бой уважно стежила за цим,
тому її команда виривається вперед.
Після запливів Олівера Клеммета та Леоні Бек,
перемогу команді приніс Флоріан Веллброк.
Німецька збірна обійшла Угорщину та Італію.
Для Веллброка це вже третя медаль
на чемпіонаті світу в Будапешті.
В його арсеналі є ще бронза та срібло.
Німці, як у 2019 році, здобули звання
чемпіонів світу у змішаній естафеті.
Колишній ультрас Кай Бернштайн
став новим президентом ФК «Герта».
Раніше 41-річний підприємець
очолював фан-групу клуба.
Зараз же він став наступником Вернера Ґеґенбауера,
який пішов у відставку після
14 років перебування на посаді.
Сьогодні останній день фіналів. Німецьким
спортсменам присудили 190 звань чемпіонів.
Однак менше, ніж півгодини тому,
сталася одна з найважливіших подій:
ухвалено рішення щодо переможців
у стрибках в довжину серед жінок.
Чемпіонка Олімпійських ігор
у Токіо Малайка Міхамбо
впевнено захистила своє звання.
28-річна жителька Гейдельбергу
підтвердила свою винятковість.
З третьої спроби вона стрибнула на відстань 6,85 м.
Звання чемпіона з триатлону у спринтерській
дистанції, що включає 750 м плавання,
20 км їзди на велосипеді та 5 км бігу,
здобув Лассе Люрс з Бушгютену.
Він виборов перемогу у
Лассе Нюґард-Прістера з Квікборна.
Пауліна Шефер-Бец з міста Хемніц
здобула чемпіонське звання у гімнастиці.
Попри незначні помилки, чемпіонка світу 2017 року
обігнала своїх суперниць.
Несподіваний момент для Олівера Відмана:
під час випробування зламалася
рукоятка 26-дюймового колеса.
А ось 20-річний чемпіон світового рівня
з Людвігсбурга захистив своє чемпіонське звання.
Після трьох фальстартів Джошуа Гартман із Кельна
випередив Овена Анса з міста Гамбург
у дистанції 200 м, показавши найкращий час - 20,32 с.
На цьому у мене все. Дякую.
У деяких регіонах погода буде неспокійною:
на сході та південному сході
буде сонячно дещо довше.
Подекуди очікується мінлива або сильна хмарність,
інколи дощі або грози.
Можливі зливи, град та сильні пориви вітру.
На заході температура становитиме 19-26°,
на сході - до 35° тепла.
На цьому ми з вами прощаємося.
Бажаємо чудового початку нового тижня.
Не пропустіть «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом о 21:45.
Передаю слово Тео Колю. До побачення.